well,
happy wednesday, greets héctor
mejía with his informative network of them in
spanish parents of students from several
public schools came out to demonstrate
this morning they ask the cis and stick
to reopen the schools for
the rest of the year currently the district
does not have  plans to allow
students to return to classrooms
full-time only pre-
kindergarten through third grade students are scheduled
to return to classrooms under the new
plan which will be hybrid starting
March 1 the two men
arrested last month in  Las Vegas
for allegedly participating in the chaos
of the Capitol will face
additional charges that include civil disorder
and for violent assault on
federal land.
where they
will eventually relocate
in the meantime it has opened once  Vaccination window
at the
Martin Luther King Senior Center June The new
clinic is only offering
coronavirus vaccines to people
over the age of 70 and
first aid workers The facility will be
open today tomorrow Thursday from 7:00
a.m. to 2:00 p.m.  in the afternoon for more
information on how to make an appointment you
can visit our home page
dotcom the golden knights team
may have been hit again by
the coronavirus the knights
unexpectedly canceled their press
conference last night and
today's practice still  the team dominated the
rink last night against the
anaheim cabs winning 5-4 in the scam blew
ring both teams are scheduled to
play tomorrow but it hasn't been made clear if
that game is still going on or not
now a look at the
weather forecast  the clouds disappeared today
wednesday making way for the sun
which will remain shining and warming
us today and tomorrow  The low temperatures
will be in the 40s and the high ones will be on
the heels of the 70s. A new system in
the Pacific could bring chances
of rain for
Friday and winds for Saturday.
Music]